so there would be the executive producer
who is greg daniels or a co-executive
producer all the fancy names
they kind of decide on the vision
and the arcs the overriding feelings of
the whole season and then your job
is more micro like you sit there and you
pitch jokes
to fix other people's scripts that's
your sort of you're supposed to be like
a little worker bee you have a lot of
good joke people but you need some story
people or you
have people who can sit around and
discuss character all day
we all pitch all the ideas out and we
work really hard sort of making an
outline and then one writer goes off and
writes the original draft and then once
you write it you sort of
it becomes the property of the staff
again and we all rewrite it
and um and then but the person who's
sort of the point person
[Music]
it's the job of the the showrunner to uh
to try and make sure that everyone feels
safe in the writer's room you know you
it's a balance because
if they feel too safe then they just
talk and talk and talk and no work gets
done
putting a writing staff together is what
i imagine
putting maybe a baseball team together
would be in that there's different
positions
and you're trying to get a balance and
you know as you're hiring
you you have a lot of good joke people
but you need some story people or you
have people who can sit around and
discuss character all day
but you need somebody who understands
dialogue and
speaks the way people speak nowadays so
at the office it was
we had six writers the first season and
then eight the second season so
for a sitcom writer's room you sit
around a room and the upper level
writers are the are kind of the only
ones for whom it's cool to like
okay i want to do an episode about this
like that would be
that would be a little presumptuous if
you were a staff writer so kind of the
well-paid people
get to come up with a big idea do they
have a different title yes so there
would be the executive producer who is
greg daniels or a co-executive producer
all the fancy names and then when you're
just like a schlub like me you're a stop
writer
and your job is to just they kind of
decide on
the vision and the arcs the overriding
feelings of the whole season
and then your job is more micro like you
will
you'll write a script and then when
they're rewriting a script
which is all happens around a big
conference room you sit there and you
pitch jokes
to fix other people's scripts that's
your sort of you're supposed to be like
a little worker bee
it's the job of the the showrunner to uh
to try and make sure that everyone feels
safe in the writer's room you know you
it's a balance
because if they feel too safe then they
just talk and talk and talk and no work
gets done
and some rooms that i've been in for
example the simpsons
is a very quiet room and there's a very
high standard for what you
have to say and that's the way they
liked it and
i remember when i was working there
they hired a pretty young writer who
just loved to talk and
drove everybody crazy because in that
little silence where they were all
you know sifting through the
possibilities and trying to think of the
funniest line he would just fill it up
with attention needing uh
stuff and so they they got rid of him
pretty quick
the way that we would start a season
we'd start with what we would call a
blue sky
period which was my favorite part of
every year
for two three four weeks sometimes if we
had a long time
every single day in the writers room was
just what if
there's no penalty there's no maybe we
can't there's no but this one conflicts
with that one
what if dwight goes to the moon what if
jim and pam
get divorced what you know just every
idea
is is valid so when it says
if your name is on the script for the
writer what did you do on that script
so when you write an episode of a show
like the office we'll have
all sat together in a room and broken
the story so breaking the story means we
just talk through every single beat okay
michael scott does this then dwight does
this there's an a story and a b
story pam and jim are on the b story and
we just take these
colored cards and the michael story will
be a yellow card
and the other b story will be a pink
card and then we just put it up on a
board
and then once that's done is there any
dialogue written for that or is it
literally just
outline it's it's um plot with little
interjections
of comedy bits like where you pitch some
dialogue
which if it kills in the room and does
really well and is in the there's a
writer's assistant who's taking notes
at transcribing everything that's said
and so that's the document you have so
if you remember
that someone who was important in the
room pitched something that made people
laugh you put it in the script
i take for me it takes me a long time to
thoroughly understand what i'm adapting
and i kind of look at it like a clock
and you take the top off and you get in
there and you figure out all the gears
and
try and really understand why everything
has been put in
the clock by the person who first made
it
and and then you can recreate it but
then there's a second step which is
to change it for the country that you're
in
and for for me it didn't i didn't change
it the first season i didn't change
until the second season
i'll usually read hundreds of spec
scripts
and then get about 40 that i
want to meet the writers of uh and then
when you're meeting them
you're pretty much just looking for
um a bottle of wine that's gone bad
you know it's like you're not you're
most people are pretty
nice and funny but some people are just
really weird and in person and you
realize
like i don't i don't want to hang out
with them for intensely for the next
10 months or something i think i was in
a lot of denial during the finale
because it was a very joyful experience
i was very happy to have the different
cast members return
like mindy and bj and steve i can't
believe you came
that's what she said it was such a kind
of a classic thing
to to set up a situation where he could
say that and
the characters were acting like
it was the most profound you know
emotional
interaction that he could say when it
was you know it was just that that's
what she said joke seemed like it was
very in character
uh well even from the pilot um
we had the actors come up with their own
stuff a lot of times
uh in the that's i think the probably
the area that has the most
um you know original generation of stuff
from the actors
and we if they if they are feeling
less than inspired there is a complete
script to to
you know everybody could do it and then
oftentimes uh
uh some of them enjoy uh you know
making stuff up around the edges
those um we call them talking heads and
those those are the best things to shoot
because they're really easy because it's
a camera on a tripod and an actor
sitting
two feet away and we yeah we do what's
written in the script and then they
they say let me try this and they try
something and we make up jokes on the
set and
and uh i don't think reign has ever not
given
for example an alternate version of
one it's really they're easy to shoot
you can shoot a hundred of them in in
ten minutes you know and so they get to
like goof around and have fun i remember
when we were shooting the pilot
and um greg called me up at home one
night
before work and i thought he was gonna
fire me
i really did because executive producers
don't usually like call the actors at
home like
the night before unless it's bad but he
called me up and he said so jenna
tomorrow
we're going to do some of your talking
heads and i was just thinking maybe you
could talk a little bit about roy
maybe where you think you guys started
your relationship
i don't want to give you any ideas i
just want to see what you can come in
with just
we'll ask you about that relationship
and you can just talk about it
that's kind of when i knew that i was on
a really special show that valued actors
input and
we were brought in to the creative
process right from the beginning and we
still do that i'm correct in
saying that each one writer leads up an
episode
and then sort of other writers help with
the editing is that a typical
television show creating a comedy or is
that atypical
um i i don't know yeah i mean one of the
writers is sort of
we all pitch all the ideas out and you
work really hard sort of making an
outline and then one writer goes off and
okay
right original draft and then once you
write it you sort of
it becomes the property of the staff
again
and we all rewrite it and um and then
but the person who's sort of the point
person is
is on it from from day one is on the set
and isn't editing and stuff
and then you know you edit it and you
get it exactly
the way that you think it's best and
then greg comes down
and points out why what you did was
stupid and terrible
and then he fixes it and makes it good
you